Ja.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Sarkaan Cialian. Ich bin die Asserbender der Stationauti.
Ich würde gerne eine Anamnese gespricht mit Ihnen dürfen und Sie sein verstanden.
Ja klar, Hauptsache mir hilft jemand ja.
Wie ist Ihr Name?
Ich heiße Frank Beathke.
Frank, könnt ihr Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bustabieren?
Ja, B-E-T-H-G-E.
Beathke.
Beathke?
Und ich bin ein Mann, Frank ist ein Herr.
Herr Beathke, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45.
45.
Ja, 45.
Wie sind Sie?
Und?
Bitte?
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin laut Pass 178.
178? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, wenn meine Wahr gerecht hat, 114 Kilo.
114.
14.
Herr Beathke, was führt Sie heute so?
Ah, wissen Sie, ich habe seit heute Nachmittag mit einmal ganz plötzlich
solche extremen Schmerzen in meinem Fuß,
und zwar im linken Fuß,
so vorne da, wo die große Zähel ist.
Das ist mit einmal auch ganz heiß und rot und tut so weh.
Das ist wie angeflogen, ja?
Und es sind ganz, ganz starke Schmerzigkeit, überhaupt nicht auftreten mit dem Fuß.
Und ich habe mich aber nicht verletzt.
Also bei der Arbeit ist mir nichts draufgefallen.
Ich trage bei der Arbeit auch Sicherheitsschuhe.
Also da ist mir nichts passiert.
Mir ist nichts drüber gefahren, nichts draufgefallen.
Aber oh, das sind solche heftigen Schmerzen, das klopft und es heiß und und brennt
und es sehr, sehr schmerzhaft.
Herr Beathke, könnten Sie bitte zeigen,
wo die Schmerzen genau sind?
Ja, also am linken Fuß, wenn wir den jetzt so nehmen,
dann wäre es praktisch hier so in diesem Bereich.
Ja, meinen Sie erste große Hörer?
Im großen Zäh, ja, im großen Zäh unten.
Genau, da tut es sehr, sehr doll wird.
Aber das strahlt in den ganzen Fuß auf.
Das fühlt sich an, als ob das gebrochen wäre.
Seit heute Vormittag haben Sie gesagt?
Nein, seit heute Nachmittag.
Ich bin direkt hierher gekommen, weil das so plötzlich gekommen ist.
Ich hatte mich heute Mittag nach der Arbeit ein bisschen hingelegt
und dann bin ich aufgewacht, weil es mit einmal so doll wie getan hat.
Wir hatten noch gut zu Mittag gegessen
und danach fing das dann mit einmal an.
Herr Beathke, unsere Anamese gespricht dauernd
um ungefähr 15 bis 20 Minuten.
Könnten Sie die Sendung an Amese gespricht halten
oder soll ich Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel verabrechen?
Nein, wenn ich das still halte, geht das sehr schlimm.
Ist es nur, wenn ich versuche, da drauf zu stehen.
Aber wenn ich das hier still halten kann, dann geht das ja.
Alles klar.
Dann könnten wir weiterreden.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass er Klopfende brennende
und schütterlern in den Ganzentursch.
Vermuten Sie etwas als Auslöser, Herr Beathke?
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen,
was solche Schmerzen im Zähn macht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich nicht verletzt.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Könnten Sie, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmasse,
wobei nun kein Schmerz, sondern am stärksten Schmerz ist?
10.
Also, das sind schon sehr, sehr krasse Schmerzen.
Ich würde sagen, zwischen 7 und 8 sind die.
Sie sind schon 7 und 8.
Hab ich etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich bin jetzt, weil ich mich so erschrocken habe,
ich bin direkt hierher gekommen.
Alles klar.
Wie helfen Sie auf jeden Fall, Herr Beathke?
Bis auf diese Schmerzen.
Falls Ihnen noch etwas Ungeweniges?
Ja, das ist mit allem auch ganz dick und rot.
Ich habe das ja angeguckt, Sie haben gedacht, was ist denn da los?
Und das fühlt sich auch heiß an.
Also, Herr Beathke,
jetzt wollte ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinen
Gesundheit hier anzustellen.
Wie sieht Ihre Schlafqualität aus?
Können Sie gut ein- oder durchschlafen?
Also, ich schnarche nachts und deswegen wache ich oft auf
oder meine Frau rempelt mich an.
Und sagt, ich soll aufhören zu schnarchen.
Aber manchmal merke ich das auch selber
und dann kann ich selber nicht einschlafen.
Also, einschlafen und durchschlafen geht beides nicht so gut.
Ist das seit Langem bekannt?
Das ist schon länger, ja.
Langem.
Ist der Appetit gut, Herr Beathke?
Ja, Sie sehen es ja, ne?
Also, meine 114 Kilo habe ich nicht von ungefähr.
Ja, ich bin ein leidenschaftlicher Esser.
Nehmen Sie Genugflüssigkeit zu sehen.
Ich meine ungefähr 2 Liter täglich.
Das kriege ich ja schon alleine mit einem Bier fast hin.
Und wenn ich dann noch ein bisschen Kaffee und Zildrinker
und bei der Arbeit, wenn es warm ist, trinke ich natürlich auch noch was.
Also, 2 Liter trinke ich bestimmt am Tag, ja.
Alles klar.
Fühlen Sie sich fiebrig, Herr Beathke?
Nee, fiebrig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dieser Fuß kocht, ne?
Sie fühlen im Fußbereich.
Da fühlt sich das heiß an.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Wie ist das mit dem Wassellassen?
Haben Sie beschwerten mit dem Wassellassen?
Nee, normal.
Nee, habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Und mit dem Schutulgang?
Ja, normal.
Das ist alles normal, würde ich sagen.
Ich kenne das nicht anders.
Herr Beathke, haben Sie in deiner Lesterzeit ungewollt?
Ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen, aber auch zum Glück nicht zugenommen.
Es ist alles stabil eigentlich.
Ich habe das Gewicht schon lange so.
Haben Sie in der Nacht,
haben Sie bemerkt, Ihnen und Ihnen danach zu warm ist?
Dass mir zu warm ist.
Ihnen danach, mussten Sie...
Ja, jetzt, wenn es sehr heiß war, dann habe ich geschwitzt in der Nacht.
Aber normalerweise,
wir haben nicht so ein warmes Schlafzimmer,
ich kann eigentlich, an der Wärme liegt es nicht.
Herr Beathke, ich möchte noch einige Fragen
so in der Fußschmerzen stellen.
Haben Sie Schwelchung bemerkt?
Das habe ich doch gesagt.
Das fühlt sich so dick und heiß an und sieht auch komisch aus.
Dick?
Und Bewegungseinstinkung?
Ja, ich kann das überhaupt nicht bewegen,
ich kann da ja nicht mal drauf treten.
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht versuchen,
mit den Zehen zu backen, das tut alles weh.
Früher hatten Sie ein Hemdbeschwer, oder?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt,
deswegen bin ich ja so erschrocken,
deswegen bin ich ja gleich gekommen.
Und nur diese Fußbereiche,
nur große Sehe, nicht andere Gelenke.
Anders tut es immer umdrehen, nicht weh.
Aber da tut es umso mehr weh.
Alles klar, danke schön, Herr Beathke.
Jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen so wie das Vorgeschicht.
Lassen Sie mir an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen zett,
das wissen Sie.
Und mein Arzt hat mir auch mal gesagt,
dass die Leute ein bisschen zu hoch sind,
aber bisher habe ich da nichts gegengenommen.
Das war mir eigentlich so ein bisschen lästig, diese Geschichte.
Seit wann leiden Sie ja ein Blutfettwerk?
Ich leide ja nicht darunter, ich merke das ja selber gar nicht.
Wenn der Arzt mir das nicht gesagt hätte,
wüsste ich das gar nicht.
Aber das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Da hat er mal so ein Check gemacht
und da hat er mir gesagt, ihre Blutfettwerte sind zu hoch.
Da hat man natürlich auch gesagt, ich soll abnehmen,
aber das ist natürlich schwierig, wenn es einem gut schmeckt.
Sie haben recht, Herr Beathke.
Ansonsten haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Nee.
Also als Kind so der Klassiker,
dass ich da mal ein blinderem Operation hatte,
aber sonst nie, ich bin immer gesund gewesen.
Wie alt waren Sie, wenn Sie operieren?
Bei der Blinder-Operation?
So zwölf.
Alles klar.
Herr Beathke, sind bei Ihnen allergie in besungsweise
um Tatsächlichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch bin
und essen kann ich nun wirklich alles, ja.
Nehmen Sie ganz kurz die Bekannte.
Nehmen Sie ganz kurz die Medikamente,
die wir gern mit besungsweise, bedarfweise ein.
Zum Beispiel gegen Blutfettwerte.
Was mir der Arzt mal gegeben hat,
ich hatte mal so eine Zeit lang ziemlich so soot brennen.
Und da hat der Arzt mir Omeprazole gegeben
und das nehme ich aber eigentlich nur ein,
wenn ich gerade heftige Beschwerden habe,
normalerweise, vergab ich nicht.
Nur Omeprazole, keine mehr.
Sonst nichts?
Und ja, was weiß ich, wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
weil ich irgendwie zu schwer gearbeitet habe
oder wenn ich einen dicken Kopf habe,
dann nehme ich wohl auch mal Aspirin ein, ja.
Herr Beathke, ist Ihr Impass komplett?
Mama, bitte, ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden, akustisch.
Ist Ihr Impass komplett?
Mein Impfpass?
Ja, Impfpass.
Oh ja, wenn ich ihn dann finde, ist er komplett.
Also ich weiß sicher, dass ich gegen Corona geimpft bin.
Und sonst ja, im Zuge der Impfungen für die Kinder
und so haben wir das immer mal aufgefrischt,
wenn uns da was aufgefallen ist, dass der Bedarf war, ja.
Und dadurch, dass ich bei der Arbeit
also viel ja auch so mit Metall
und ja, was, was ich so mit schmutzigen Sachen auch zu tun habe,
habe ich auch immer mal wieder eine Tätternussimpfung bekommen.
Haben Sie ihn zufällig dabei, Herr Beathke?
Nee, der liegt natürlich zu Hause, den habe ich in der Eile vergessen, ja.
Alles klar, kein Problem.
Sind Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten irgendwo hingereist?
Ja, wir waren mal an der Nordsee, aber sonst waren wir nicht weg.
Herr Beathke, wir sind fast fertig mit unserer Manamesegeschichte.
Nur ein paar Fragen noch.
Sind Sie raucht?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu Sie?
Ja, also Alkohol.
Regelmäßig trinke ich ein paar Flaschen Bier am Tag, ja.
Täglich ein Flasche Bier?
Nein, täglich zwei, drei Flaschen.
Zwei, drei.
Ansonsten nehmen Sie doch alle ein Bier.
Nee, sonst, also mal schnappst, wenn es etwas zu feiern hebt,
oder noch ein Sekt oben drauf oder so.
Aber also, regelmäßig trinke ich das Bier.
Herr Beathke, nächste Frage ist eine Routine.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit anderen Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ja.
Nee, also für so einen Quatsch habe ich wirklich keine Zeit.
Nein.
Alles klar.
Nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer familiären Manamese.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Nee, das kann man wirklich nicht sagen.
Also meine Mutter ist zum Glück gesund, aber mein Vater,
der ist schon verstorben, der hatte Darmkrebs.
Wegen Darmkrebs.
Wie hat bei Ihrem Vater, wenn er starrt?
Oh, der war 82.
Ihre Mutter hat keine chronische Erkrankung.
Wüsste nicht, dass die irgendwas hat?
Ich glaube, die ist ziemlich gesund.
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Herr Beathke, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie mit Ihrer Frau
nicht richtig verstanden.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, das letzte hat es da und sind brum.
Das ist natürlich unser Sorgenkind.
Herr Beathke, Sie sind berustetik.
Ja, ich arbeite als Maschinenschlosser.
Und da in der Werkstatt geht es ziemlich rupig zu.
Deswegen habe ich auch erst gedacht, ich hätte mich da verletzt.
Aber wie gesagt, da ist nichts passiert.
Sie haben keine Verletzungen, keine Umfragen.
Maschine, als Maschinen-Schlosser.
Ich repariere Maschinen und baue sie zusammen.
Alles klar.
Herr Beathke, meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigsten Fragen gestattet.
Was soll ich wissen?
Ich wüsste jetzt natürlich gerne, woher es kommt, dass es solche Schmerzen sind.
Und was kann man dagegen machen?
Herr Beathke, ich habe schon meine Vermittungen.
Aber es ist noch zu viel, etwas Bestimmtes zu sagen.
Zuerst möchte ich die Köpferlihung untersuchen.
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Dann mit den Befunden prähen wir zusammen.
Ja, okay.
Und wird das lange dauern?
Ich würde ein paar Stunden im Kauf nehmen.
Also muss ich ein paar Stunden rechnen.
Dann rufe ich gleich noch bei meiner Familie an.
Das bin ich auch nicht warten.
Alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Hallo Herr Beathke.
Ernere Sie sich ausgewogen oder wie oft essen Sie Fleisch oder Fleischprodukte?
Fleisch esse ich am liebsten zu jeder Mahlzeit.
Ich könnte schon zum Frühstückwurst essen.
Okay, danke schön.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Sehnschmerzen, Gena-Beschreibe,
die Zehnschmerzen?
Ja, sie haben schon gesagt und gerötet.
Ja, sie sind klopfende und stechende Schmerzen.
Klopfende und stechende.
Was sieht Ihre Schweldung aus?
Gerötet.
Es ist gerötet, ja.
Gerötet und ja so angeschwollt.
Gibt es Beschenthausen, die haben nicht erwähnt?
Mit einem Mal hat es angefangen.
Ich kann nicht erkennen, dass es einen Auswürser gibt.
Das ist ja auch das erste Mal.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch sofort hergekommen,
weil ich das nicht einordnen konnte.
Kontrollieren Sie Ihre Fußgegenpilze zum Beispiel?
Wie viele Fußpilze?
Ja, gut.
Dadurch, dass ich regelmäßig Arbeitsschuhe,
also so Sicherheitsschuhe trage,
da muss man schon zwischendurch mal gucken,
aber Fußpilze habe ich nicht.
Rechte Seite, Bein, irgendwelche Geschwollung ist?
Ist das rechte Bein aufgeschwollt?
Nein, das ist jetzt im Augenblick noch unauffällig gewesen.
Ich hoffe, das fängt nicht auch noch an.
Haben Sie allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Hat er verneint, er hat gefragt und der Doktor hat gefragt
und ich habe das verneint.
Okay.
Guten Abend Herr Betr.
Hallo, seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach, schon lange, seit ich 16 bin.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Erkältung oder Mandelentzündung in den letzten Monaten?
Eine Erkältung?
Ja, mal so ein bisschen husten, schluckfen hatte ich schon,
aber eine Mandelentzündung hatte ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie unter Herzstraßen oder Herzstolpern?
Nein, mit Herzen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur diese Fußschmerzen, diese schrecklichen.
Fühlen Sie sie allgemein abgeschlagen?
Ja, jetzt im Augenblick bin ich schon beeinträchtigt
durch diese starken Schmerzen.
Aber eigentlich, vorher habe ich mich nicht schlecht gefühlt.
Okay.
Gibt es an der Betreöffelern Stelle Mückenstich
oder eine kleine Wunde?
Also ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Ich wüsste aber nicht, wo mich Insekten gestochen haben sollten.
Also ich habe, aber danach habe ich wirklich nicht geguckt,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Wir haben gesagt, Sie können nicht auf dem linken Bein auftreten.
Genau, auf dem linken Fuß.
Ich habe uns bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine muskulschwere
oder taubhausgefühle oder mit taubhausgefühl habe ich nicht.
An den Muskeln liegt das nicht.
Es ist nur so schmerzhaft, dass ich da nicht draufstehen kann.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Können wir als erstes wieder anfangen?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen. Darf ich Sie vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Der 45-jährige Patient, Herr Franz Betges, stellte sich heute, wegen seit heute Nachmittag,
hat sich aufgetreten, aufgeprägt, persistiert, eine Klopfendische, im großen Zähler,
mit der Rötung, Schwellung und überwahrungs-soviel Messbedingten,
Bewegungs-Einschränkungen, bei uns auf der Station.
Die aktuelle Schmerzintensität liegt laut dem Patientin bei 7 bis 8 auf einer Schmasskala.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient, der auf der Station ist,
mit dem Schlafstöhrung, der auf der Station ist,
mit dem Schlafstöhrung, der auf der Station ist.
Ich habe seit einem Tag den Patienten von der Hypercholester,
Da musste sich eine Operation unterziehen.
Die Fragen allergieren sowie Unverträglichkeiten wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Andern Medikamenten nimmt der Patient um eine Prasortablet, so wie aus der Tabletin bei Bedarf ein.
Der Info ist komplett. Die Reise an Amnesien ist in den letzten 6 Monaten unerfällig.
Der Patient ist kein Raucher. Alkoholkonsum beträgt bei zwei, drei Flaschen Bier täglich, seit 6 und 10 Lebensjahr.
Der Patient lebt mit seiner Frau, hat drei Kinder.
Der Erkirekind leidet am Down-Centrum.
Die jüngste Verstaltung.
Bei der Vorstellung präsentiert sich der Patient im normalen Allgemeinszustand, so wie Adiposen, Ernährungszustand.
Der Patient ist 178 cm, der Patient ist 114 kg.
Er ist als Maschine in einem Werkstatt berüstet.
Was ist denn jetzt die Verlachtreagnose?
Die Erkorene einer mnestischen Angabe in deutener Hessen, akut entschuldigen, nicht Anfall hin.
Differenzial der Durchsicht, kommunin, atritis, so wie Rheuma im Betracht.
Und das könnte es möglicherweise noch sein?
Keine Verletzung, deswegen, ich sage nicht.
Haben Sie danach nach der Verletzung gefragt?
Entschuldigung.
Hatten Sie nach einer Verletzung den Patienten gefragt?
Ja.
Und war nix?
Nein, keine Verletzung.
Was könnte es unter Umständen noch sein?
Urkus kurd, atritis, üdika.
Eine Durchblutungsstörung.
Dass er eine Durchblutungsstörung im Fuß hat, könnte auch sehr schmerzhaft sein.
Aber atritis, üdika, möglich.
Hat er schon gesagt, Geht Anfall?
Ja, okay.
Fußpilzeinfektion?
Fußpilzeinfektion, ja, die müsste schon sehr hoch explodiert sein.
Linfedimp?
Ja, ein Grundgelenk, ja, nicht so wahnsinnig.
Aber die ist nicht ganz so.
Ja, also könnte, eine PAVK oder so etwas müsste man ausschließen, würde ich sagen.
Atanisch, groß sehen, ansündliche und schmerzhafte bedeutet,
hallux di judus.
Ja, beziehungsweise, wie sagen wir, wie sagen wir für diesen Symptomkomplex,
wenn das Großzehn Grundgelenk so extrem schmerzhaft ist?
Podagra, protogra.
Protogra, fussgis.
Bitte?
Protogra.
Podagra, also in Deutschland sagen wir Podagra, das ist typisch für die, ja, genau.
Also Entzündung des Fußzehn Grundgelenk als Symptom der Gicht.
Okay, gut. Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten diagnostisch?
Ja, so erst würde ich Gott Heilig und Tarzanum.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Auf der Spektion auf Überwartung, Schwellung, Rötung des Betroffenenbereits,
Allpassion des Betroffenengelenkens Bewegungseinschränkungen.
Und was machen Sie mit dem anderen Fuß? Bleibt ihr angezogen?
Fuß.
Der rechte Fuß, was machen Sie mit dem?
Vergleichen.
Ja, genau.
Mit dem rechte Fuß vergleichen.
Genau.
Dann kann man das besser einsetzen.
Gut, und was gucken Sie noch?
Ja, in Rahmen der Routineuntersuchung für die Herz- und Lungenoskulation.
Okay, ja.
Und was machen Sie weiter?
Blutabnehmen.
Im Blutbild kontrolliere ich Entzündungsparameter.
Nieren Leberwärter, Harnsäure, Sonders.
Ja, genau.
Das ist auch nicht der Fokus.
Dass man guckt, ist die Harnsäure erhöht.
Was erwarten Sie?
Für Harnsäure, meinen Sie?
Harnsäure erhöht die Harnsäure.
Wir erwarten da...
Ja, mehr als 6 mg des Liter vielleicht.
Ja, genau.
Erinnerung.
Und die Harnsäure, die ich in der Harnsäure verwendet habe,
dann...
Abaratenuntersuchungen würde ich röntgen durführen.
Ja, weshalb würden Sie eine Röntgenuntersuchung machen?
Damit wir auch Silicen und andere Verletzungen
Knochen brachen.
Genau, eine Faktur aus...
Das wäre vielleicht noch so eine denkbare Differenzialdiagose,
die wir damit reinnehmen sollten,
dass wir überlegen,
das könnte auch eine spontanen Faktur sein.
Denn ich meine, der bringt ja doch ordentlich Gewicht
auf sein Fußgewölbe damit.
Ja, gut, also Sie röntgen.
Und wenn sich der erhöhte Serumharnspiegel da...
Harnsäurespiegel bestätigt, was machen Sie dann?
Therapie, meinen Sie, oder?
Ja, also dann hätten wir die Bestätigung,
dann hätten wir die Bestätigung.
Und das würde man dann machen.
Aber erste Diagose.
Die Stamphal-Erste Diagose.
Ist die erste Diagose?
Ja, ja.
Ist die Diagose?
Ja, der Patient hat ausgeprägtisch mercy,
deswegen ist das Ausreichende Analgesi.
Genau, Ausreichende Analgesi.
Und die Pyrithnisolone kann sein,
ja, kann helfen,
Steroid, Steroid-Meinie.
Steroid?
Ja, Steroid.
Also, das ist eine senkende Therapie,
Allopyrinol, würde ich verpassen.
Stimmt.
Allopyrinol.
Alle Purinol, sag mir, was Sie verstehen.
Das ist für Langfristig, ne?
Residivprophylaxie.
Residivprophylaxie ist Allopyrinol erforderlich.
Genau, Kolchizin, genau.
Das habe ich ja auf dem Zettel stehen.
Dass man Kolchizin im Akut-Anfall gibt, ne?
Nein, Herr Chefrauff,
Akut-Anfalle müssen wir erstmal gut gekocht werden.
Dann kochen sie.
Ah, okay, gut.
Ja, bei Makut-Anfall gibt es ja Steroids,
so wie Analgetikum zusammen, dann machen wir
Kolchizin Therapie.
Ja, ich habe vergesst zu erwähnen, ja.
Gut, und ja, was würde man den Patienten
langfristig empfehlen?
Diese beschwerden sich häufig
verbumpt mit Alkohol,
so wie Fleisch, Proteinarmessen.
Deswegen würde ich Ernährungssperratur empfehlen.
Proteinreichemessen.
Proteinreich, ja.
Reifenessen, ja, ja, ja.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte Reifenessen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Unser Patient hat keine Ernährung,
aber er ist übergewicht.
Also es wirkt die Normalisierung des Körpergewichtes
auch Ernährungssperratur empfehlen.
Genau.
Das sind sicherlich die Punkte.
Und ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Das wissen Sie wahrscheinlich alle besser.
Wie schnell geht so ein Gichtanfall vorbei?
Bei akute Anfall hat er wirklich sehr stark geschmackt.
Und die Frage ist, wie lange hält das an, wenn man den jetzt mit Schmerzmittel behandelt und mit
diesen Theroid? Wie schnell wird es besser für den?
Ja, für Autherapie. Es ist nicht sehr lange dauert.
Da wird nicht lange. Und dann reguliert er sich auch von alleine wieder runter und dann gehen auch diese Entzündung
Phänomene wieder weg.
Es gibt eine Massname, Frau Gerholt. Es gibt eine Massname, erst mal hochtosiert,
und dann langsam, langsam, nicht wirklich.
20 Tage. Aber die Schmerzen hat ja noch schneller weg.
Ja, schneller weg, aber wir müssen ja kurz durch die Massname.
Und die muss man dann ausschleichen, ne?
Ja, ja.
Aber die, also ich meine, diese Schmerzen kriegt man noch relativ zügig in den Griff, oder?
Ja.
Die Adakio-Atachmerz-Therapie mit Pyrätinuselon, das ist, sind reicht.
Und dann, dann koş ich es, aber nicht mehr diese Medikamente, die Ursache sind.
Und die haben wir bekämpfen, ja, klar.
Meine Frage war, müsste mir Allopinol lange Zeit verbrechen.
Als Dauermedikament. Ja, meine Frage war jetzt nochmal, wie lange hält dieser akute Gicht-Anfall an?
Gibt es da jemanden, der Erfahrung hat? Ich weiß es nämlich nicht.
Ich habe nur einen Patient gesehen im Hausarztpraxis und die akute heftige Schmerzen hat ungefähr ein paar Tage gedauert.
Ach doch, wenige Tage, okay. Genau.
Ja, danke schön. Das war die Info genau, die ich haben wollte. Danke sehr.
Ja, okay. Also nach einigen Tagen geht es dem wieder besser und dann kann der auch wieder mit seinem Fuß laufen und auftreten.
Gut, ja, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen von unserem Schema abgekommen.
Ich bin natürlich jetzt wieder die Obererstin und sage dann also, ja, also Herr Kollege, dann schauen Sie doch mal, was mit dem Patienten ist.
Ich bin gespannt, wenn an den Röntgenbildern irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten sind, dann zeigen Sie mir die Bitte.
Und ich bin natürlich auch sehr gespannt auf die Laborwerte und dann können wir nachher nochmal zusammen nach dem Patienten gucken. Ja? Okay?
Ich schuldigung, ich konnte nicht ganz gut feststellen. Was soll ich machen jetzt?
Ah, okay. Also die Oberärztin hat jetzt, also wir haben jetzt ja über andere Sachen geredet und ich bin ein bisschen aus der Rolle rausgeschlüpft.
Jetzt sagt die Oberärztin nochmal, ja, also gucken Sie nochmal nach dem Patienten und berichten Sie mir über Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Ja? Also ich möchte das Röntgenbild gerne sehen und ich möchte auch die Laborwerte gerne sehen, ja, wenn Sie den Patienten untersucht haben.
Und dann gucken wir weiter, ja?
Gut, ja, Sie sind, glaube ich, sehr souverän mit der Sprache.
Da habe ich eigentlich wenig Grund zum Kritisieren gefunden.
Sie sprechen manchmal ein bisschen, ja, wie soll ich sagen, manchmal konnte ich sie nicht so ganz gut verstehen,
aber ich würde schon sagen, dass die ganzen Formulierungen ziemlich afterein waren.
Nur eine Sache habe ich mir aufgeschrieben. Wir helfen Sie! Nein, wir helfen Ihnen!
Ja, ja, Ihnen.
Ihr habt es sofort gemerkt, wenn ich sage, ja.
Ja, gut, also wir helfen Ihnen.
Ja, und, ja, und was mir aufgefallen ist, Ihr Anfangsatz, der war sehr solide formuliert.
Er war zwar auch wieder sehr vollgestockt mit Informationen, Sie haben sehr viele Infos da reingepackt,
aber es ist Ihnen gelungen, den roten Faden von Ihrem Satz zu behalten, ja?
Also, er stellte sich mit dem Tra-la-la-Hubsa-sa, was es alles war, vor, ja?
Also, das fand ich ziemlich gelungen, wobei ich immer denke, im normalen Fall würde man so nicht sprechen,
sondern das ist so ein typischer Text, den man so schreiben würde, ja?
Ja, wenn man spricht, macht man eigentlich nicht solche komplizierten langen Sätze,
sondern dann unterbricht man eigentlich häufiger, damit die anderen auch noch mitkommen.
Aber für eine geschriebene Formulierung wäre es natürlich perfekt gewesen.
Und wie gesagt, es war auch sehr exakt formuliert, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Wenn irgendwas zwischendurch war, habe ich immer gleich gemäckert, zum Beispiel mit der Tochter
oder mit dem jüngsten Kind, was das Down-Syndrom hat und nicht das Älteste.
Und alles andere war, glaube ich, ja, die Schmerzgala war drin.
Und als ich überlege, irgendwas war mir eben noch beim Besprechen aufgefallen.
Augenblick mal eben gucken.
Ach so, ja, das fand ich gut, dass Sie nochmal erwähnt haben.
Sie haben ja am Anfang Größe und Gewicht nicht gesagt, aber dass Sie nachher nochmal darauf hingewiesen haben,
dass der Patient eben deutlich übergewichtig ist.
Weil das natürlich im Zusammenhang jetzt mit der Diagnose eine klar wichtige Information war.
Ja, gut, insofern würde ich sagen, das war für den Staat doch super.
Ja, heute ist, jetzt muss ich überlegen, Dienstag.
Wir sehen uns Sonnastag schon wieder, übermorgen.
Ja.